hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition it's all
it is a ferocious vs. onigiri one of the
candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament and some of you said that I'm
pronouncing ferocious incorrectly that
it's actually firoozeh but as I do not
know how to pronounce the surnames from
from Iran if any of you are from Iran do
a comment in the comment section below
is it is it actually future and not for
Rosa but okay that being said let's
check it out is it's a very very
instructive game so without further ado
i'll Edessa
opens with d4 and like we said so far
after four rounds with lee so is in the
lead we after beating none other than
Ali there's a few rows I'm gonna go with
Raja unless you guys actually you know
this side of this Perugia but okay c4 we
have east six nights the c3 and Bishop
to e7 by Geary we have a seek after Sun
d5e capture Sun d5 and now Bishop to f4
so strengthening the central gear
replace c6 we have Queen to c2 Alireza
develops the Queen and Knight to f6
preparing the castle we have III and now
that the bishop is out of the cage Geary
immediately starts attacking it with the
Knights to h5 since the Queen left at
the d1 square so Bishop to e5 getting
out of the way and now Geary continues
pursuing the bishop we have Knight to d7
the g7 point is defended so it's not a
problem
and now Bishop to e2 this has all been
played before basically offering Knight
captures Forbush of Kafiristan h5 and
there is one game well there are
actually three games where Knight back
to f6 was played but in those games
black didn't really achieve any any wins
and I think only one game ended in a
draw that black went in the back with
the night so Knight captures an e5 by
giri with deke actress on e5 now taking
away the f6 square for the knight and
saying what do you want to do with the
h5 night g6 by Gary and now Bishop
captures an h5 we have G captures on h5
and now other days already gave up not
only one of the bishops but both of the
bishop so it's gonna be a very
interesting game how the two knights
a pair of against the bishop pair in
this setup so night GTE - preparing to
bring the knight over to f4 and now f6
now this position has been reached
before and f6 is the top move
recommended by the engine so this is
still I believe preparation by both of
them we've each captures Bishop
characters and now rook to d1 as the
Queen is still on the 8th so I moved
like a 4 come in to mind where black
will be unable to capture and so on so
here there is one game where Queens that
east 7 was played but here Gary just
castles King side and it is as of move
14 that we have a completely new game
now if you look at it okay I mean that
doesn't seem like the greatest castle of
all time since the Kings the pawn
structure is really messed up here but a
Larissa doesn't have any bishops so it's
not gonna be eat all that easy to attack
the black King as especially with the
with the dark square bishop so nicely
covering this diagonal and the light
square bishop will of course also help
out with with the defense if he's
perhaps you know gets this diagonal but
okay Ally there's our castles and we
have kinked h8 now also giving might
have some ideas of using the G file for
for attacking the White King with efore
now as we already mentioned now the
Queen's still on the 8th so you cannot
capture and now d4 by Gary and holidays
of course ignores it since a giri will
not be able to capture either now we
have Knight to f4 just improving the
position of the night also putting
pressure on the h5 point but Giri makes
it impossible at the capture pawn he
goes to Bishop to e5 now attacking the
knight and now if you if you captured
the point in Queen to h4 just puts puts
white in a losing position since this is
not what the threat of checkmate your
knight is hanging checkmate this is
being threatened you also on pin so D
captures and c3 is a threat and the
white will simply not be able to take
care of all of the threats so after
Bishop e5 we have Knight back to d3
now with the idea that if that if you
capture now then just Knight captures an
e5 opens up a discovery here but the
black will really feel the absence of
the dark square Bishop for exam
if Queen to f6 you're just gonna capture
on c3 and now it's gonna be really
problematic for for black to play like
even a normal move Bishop to g4 just in
the rook to d6 and white just gets too
too much over the position f4 is coming
next you're gonna play f5 and of course
the the route cannot be captured due to
the double check from the knight and the
Queen and after you move well just
Knight captures and these six wins wins
the game so after Knight to d3 giri just
goes back Bishop to g7 and now we have
Knight back to e 2 preparing a four-man
attack against the d4 pawn but also
making it problematic for black to
defend upon with c5 as the Queen and the
knight just guarded and b6 is just met
with Queen captures and c6 so h4 by giri
preparing to push h3 so ali reza pushes
h3 not allowing it we have Queen to e7
now putting pressure on the e4 pawn and
now II five asking do you want to
capture on e5 and it's really not a pawn
sacrifice and even if it was a the black
was winning upon you do not want to give
up your dark square bishop since it will
be extremely hard to defend the position
for example if captures captures and
captures you even win back the pond with
to the immediate route characters and d4
so really there's no point for for black
in doing this so after E 5 rook to b8
putting the rook behind the passed pawn
makes sense
and now Alireza goes for f4 I just
cementing his past passed pawn here and
now if Geary allows f5 f6 it's it's just
game over so he has to prevent it he
continues to development Bishop to f5
getting the bishop into the game nicely
painting the night here and also
preventing the further expansion of the
pawns
so King to h2 now Allah raised a freeze
the g1 square for the knight he wants to
go Knight G 1 to F 3 and then well see
we see see where he's gonna take it from
there we have Queen that e-cigs by giri
well a better Square for the Queen also
pressuring the King side the pressuring
referring the a to pawn but Allah days
are simply continues with Knight to g1
and now what do you play here
well Geary continues Bishop to h6 now
puts pressure
to this bone now if Knight to f3 then
the pond will be you will be able to
capture the point since the knight is
pinned and the pond will be undefended
but it is a place it anyway and it's a
it's a really interesting idea because
if you go for this Bishop captures on f4
then you get a nightcap turn f4 because
yes Bishop captures Queen but the black
Queen is also under attack so here we
would have captures captures now you
would have characters characters and now
again you would have Bishop captures on
f3 and now before recapturing first you
deliver a check on f7 and after the King
moves only now you recapture and Alireza
ends up being up a piece of course
completely winning so after this night
to have to remove Geary first prepares
the capture with Queen back to e7 now
the bishop will be able to capture sense
that after the night f4 the queen is no
longer on e6
so King to h1 and now well king to h1
Alireza does not want Bishop captures an
effort to come with check he prepares a
little surprise Bishop captures on f4
and now well you win a pawn but also you
put your two bishops in front of the
rook on f1 so Queen the c5 attacking
gear is queen on e7 we have Queen
captures on c5 Knight captures on c5 now
it could be dangerous
after the knight moves as both of the
bishops are you know in front of the
rook
so Bishop the c2 sorry bishop the c2
while attacking the roof making it
impossible for the rook to for the group
to attack the bishop since the bishop
covers the dark squares we have rook
captures on d4 now putting pressure on
this bishop and the now rook captures on
d4 we have Knight captures on d4 and now
both of the bishops are hanging but it's
not a problem since
Geary has Bishop to e3 and now going for
if captures then captures but Alireza
just goes Knight ct-6 and this is one of
the one of the examples where the two
knights really are dominating the bishop
pair so bishop back to g6 and now rook
the f3 push pushing the bishop further
back of course ali reza does not have a
problem with trading bishop for a knight
as well p he eliminates
Bishop pair so Bishop back to h6 and now
Knight to f5 and here a Giri has to make
a decision whether to capture on f5 or
to further continues yeah evading the
night with the bishop so one of the
options of course is Bishop to c1 you go
after the b2 pawn after b3 is played
then you go rook to e8 you have to get
the rook into the game and now we get
this very interesting position for
example night FG 7 guards the night you
don't want to move the knight otherwise
you lose the pawn and hear that the roof
is under attack so you have to move the
rook but now it's well it's just a weird
position when you have the Knights
guarding each other so if Bishop h6
could be a problem for white but then
you might bring the knight back but then
here we might bring the rook back so we
could have a nice draw by repetition so
it's really weird Giri decided to not go
for this now but ok after Knight to a5
giving in fact decided to trade here
Bishop captures an f5 rook captures on
f5 and now although you could start by
not that but bringing the rook into the
game immediately first Bishop to e3
controlling all of the squares the
knight has to retreat now preparing to
attack it with rook to e8 and here
rook to f3 now attacking Geary's bishop
and here again
Bishop to c1 just moving the bishop
would seem like the way to go but Giri
just decides to go into a rook and pawn
endgame so here we have looked I ate my
giri and ali reza obliges of course
route captors and III rook captures on
e6 and now King the g1 starting to bring
the King into the game which is what you
always want to do in an endgame kink the
g7 with King f2 King to g6 and now rook
to e4 and now it's a it's a bit a bit of
a problem for Geary since if King to f5
then you lose this point you lose this
pond and these points become weak and
another problem is if King g5 defending
just rook g4 check again if you move the
king with the pawns will fall and if you
continue defending with something like
this then rook g7 again you have
problems defending so here all addresses
position is just much more active so
instead Gary wants rook back to e7 but
now King f3
our reza starts improving the position
of his King King to f5 and
we have a trade route cat person aged 15
capture sunny 5 and the now look the e
for check all it has a forces to go into
a king and Pony and game we have king to
f6 and the now rook captures on e7 King
captures on e7 and now King to f4 and
King to f6 so if you look at it it's a
equal material ali reza has a a bit more
of an active king since the king is
already on the fourth rank and he has a
two-to-one advantage on the Kings side
and there's a three-to-two advantage on
the Queen side so ali reza starts with G
for preventing giri from playing age 5
to control the two points with one pawn
and now here's the really impressive
moment of the game like giri has to make
a move so it's if he plays h6 ali reza
will just play h4 and again ask Gary
what do you want to do you have to
decide what to do with the Queen side
another thing if you play something like
b5 then b4 just completely eliminates
all of your play on the Queen side if
instead of a b5 you go c5 just a 4 and
again black has very limited play on the
on the Queen side if b6 just b3 if a 6
you will again play h4 and there's a
problem if b5 then you just go a 5 and
here if you want to create a passed pawn
with c4 characters captures and King e4
and the the black King cannot reach any
of the points here but the White King
will just pick up pick off this pawn and
it will be a winning end game for white
so that's the problem for Geary's so in
the end Gary decided for a 5 but now
pause the video and with the information
I've just given you feel free to find
the the best and the the winning move
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being
such an excellent and game player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's a 4 this is why it's
important you have to eliminate black's
counter play on the Queen side and by
eliminated Lux counter play on the Queen
side it means that b5 doesn't isn't good
for black if beef I was was possible for
black then it wouldn't be a problem for
Geary
however if
five it's incredible but we actually
reach an endgame if you've ever seen the
movie searching for bobby fisher' with
young Josh Waitzkin well I'll just show
it to you if B 3 of course you want to
defend you don't want to create any pass
bonds be captures be captures on a four
and now okay you have a task see poncey
five we have h 4 C 4 and now you start
bringing the King King e 4 C 3 King 2 D
3 and now King e 5 King captors and C 3
of course the black King goes after the
pawns here King to see for King captain
g4 King B 5 team captures here King
captures here and now the two outside
passed pawns like in the movie searching
for Bobby Fischer King g5 black makes
way for the pawn king b6 why does the
same a okay it's not the same because in
the movie the the promotion came with
check so we're not gonna you know set it
up like that here but okay
h5 we have 85h 486 h3 a 7 h2 and now a 8
Queen guards the queening square so it's
it's a very poetic and game so that's
why after Ali raises a 4 B 5 runs into
runs into a dead end and without without
the move b5 there's just nothing to play
for Geary
so Geary of course played h6 but now h4
if the Geary's move there is nothing
there is no good move here if you if you
try something like here just g5 or even
G captures on h5 it doesn't really
matter you create a defended passed pawn
that's just game over
and if King to e6 then which was played
in the game ali reza just plays g5 with
HK % g5 team captures and g5 now
creating the outside passed pawn king to
f7 by giri king to f5 and now b5 by
theory but here ali reza just played
King t5 and it was in this position
unmoved 51 that onigiri onigiri resigned
the game and then excellent victory for
all areas of Russia who catches up to
Wesley so as the the two leaders of the
tournament so really impressive
impressive play against one of the
candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament onigiri now the the reason he
decided that he resigned here is well
the king has to stay
to keep an eye on the outside past H
pawn and you don't have anything to play
on the Queen side for example well I
mean whatever you play before you you
cannot break through the King will just
come here pick up this pawn pick up this
pond pick up this one it's there are no
moves here so I'm really really
impressive stuff by ali reza and a
couple of weird decisions by giri in the
endgame now giving up first the bishop
pair then trading into a routine game
then just go into a king and ponen game
with with a with a worse king position
so now and in the end it all culminated
in other days are winning this beautiful
endgame so I also prepare the standings
here they are after five rounds there we
have it Wesley so and Alireza Ferrara
with three and a half out of five then
Fabiano Caruana jordan forest and
Vladislav Artemia with three out of five
with two and a half we have a lot of
people Jeffrey's young young sister Duda
Vishwanathan Anand the Magnus Carlsen
and Daniel Dube of Carson and young
street of Duda still just chillin each
with five draws then with two points
onigiri and Nikita fatigue of with one
and a half year young he and Vlad Slavko
have still struggling in last place with
one point only only two draws but that's
you know that's the difference between
the challengers and the Masters edition
it would seem so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Daniel Levy Under Armour was your
Pietrus pinkish Robert Kretchmer and
burn Island home for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the start of
Steel masters edition the coverage of
the Women's World Championship and of
course the newly started Paul Morphy
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day